what's happening you savages daddy and
mercy and breakfast this morning yeah
yeah that's right tell them what's
happening people what's happening people
that's right what happened Shawn cocoa
krispies and stop Li Shan the cocoa
krispies go pc Cocoa Krispies there you
go there you go people this is what
family is all about eating cocoa
krispies I do it you can do it say hello
America hello see what's happening
what's crackalackin can't do it yeah you
could do just right there say what's
happening are you guys doing here eat
what are you eating cocoa krispies I
mean Coco please that's right that's an
American family my little princess look
at her she's eating my ball now she's a
savage like her dad and this is what
it's all about sometime people it's the
lord's day what uncle Joey you know when
I was a kid I hate my cocoa krispies cuz
the milk turn chocolate and I can't deal
with this other stuff you don't think
the Milky I'm gonna drink with those
cocoa krispies we're gonna have
pre-diabetic breakfast but who cares its
family right right Solomon family
followed that's right love you guys have
a great day stay black beige family say
it's family oops you got some chocolate
milk say it's family and family stay
black say stay black paper